yeah dude welcome to another wild ride
with stevo this one's crazy because i
actually wore
shoes and of course i love this guy
and i couldn't wait to give him stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole which is now
finally available
on amazon plus i believe we've got it
stocked everywhere so you can get it on
prime almost no matter where you live
oh dude this stuff's delicious but i
digress
ladies and gentlemen brendan schaub
yeah what's up dude wow there's a lot to
talk about man yeah
first off thank you for for doing this
man oh thank you man thanks for making
it easy and coming to the crib
yeah dude you can always tell when
somebody is a podcaster because it's
so much easier to arrange a podcast yeah
yeah dude trying to book podcasts
guests is exhausting
it's it's one of the worst things i've
kind of stopped doing it
um with one of the shows i do showtime
books most the guys but it's just a
beast man then also
like i do so many shows a week i
constantly have to carry you know you
like you're the life
you're the engine of the show so i
constantly have to come up with stuff
so it's rare i do other people's
podcasts but i was excited to do this
oh man well thank you and as you said we
came to your
crib i'm just [ __ ] blown away by your
house i set the color of our sign to
green
oh nice because you're obviously rolling
and dough dude
how long have you lived in this house uh
about two years now
wow dude it's uh your porsche
yep yep how many cars you got uh
four nice four cars yeah podcasting and
stand up man it's
it's the good life i mean that's the
thing dude like i
i i saw this documentary on
uh netflix and for anybody who doesn't
know if you've been living under a rock
of course brendan schaub
is a former ufc heavyweight fighter
uh turned stand-up comedian and
podcaster
and uh okay so i watched this
documentary on netflix called
the hurt business did you see that the
hurt bit i'm trying to think what
which one was that it was uh about mma
it was about fighters um i suppose
mostly ufc
daniel cormier was heavily featured on
it in any case they go into just kind of
like
the stories of all these ufc fighters
and you you quickly learn
that the the norm is for people to
devote their lives to fighting yes like
even at the
highest levels in the ufc really not
make much money at all
utterly destroy their bodies and even
maybe their brains
and then at the end of their run just
left
with absolutely nothing to show for it
literally
nothing but probably ct and
you know a lot of these guys you know
they look at like a conor mcgregor or
ronda rousey or these big boys
and they're the the less than .001
percent
who literally can ride after the sunset
with their money there's not many of
them so
um it's just a sad story man the other
thing is is
you know in these other leagues they're
kind of compensated you know they're so
compensated
that after the fact they still have
health insurance or
401k or something like that a lot of
these guys futures is you know working
the ufc gyms holding mitts
and 100 it's such a bummer man and uh
we we we had rhonda on the podcast
and when i expressed that to her it was
crazy she said
well oh no dude like if it wasn't for
the ufc
if it wasn't for these fighting
organizations then uh like olympic
athletes wouldn't have anything to do to
make money
you know she had like this other option
that's her perspective right because she
came from being an olympian
but then also you're talking you know
if you ask patrick mahomes how's the nfl
he's like that's great dude
but you asked another dude like it sucks
man you know so
like ronda's experience it was great for
her and it worked out for her but
you know for the rest of the league the
majority of them don't have that
experience right
i remember dana white said uh when chuck
ledell was fighting
tito and the other fight he's like we
actually pay him not to fight
chuck yeah is i mean i mean maybe when
he got older but
dana said it best and fighters should
take note of this
he said fighting the ufc isn't a career
it's an opportunity
so i mean you gotta appreciate dana just
put it all out there he's like i'm not
saying this is a career for most people
it's not it's an opportunity
and for some people they you know they
hit while the iron's hot and
they make a living doing it so you know
it is what it but that
again it's not a knock on the ufc or in
the o'connor or ronda or
khabib or you know these guys making
real money or style bender
it's uh it's the nature of sports style
bender i'm
just falling in love with that kid more
and more i told rogan
so after star bender's last fight uh
when he knocked out paulo costa
i text rogan i said if aliens came to
the earth they're like what's mixed
martial arts i would send them
one person and be style bender yeah like
this is what it is
he's our guy he's the best we have to
offer dude
it's so i i just saw how he defended the
whole uh
bringing up jon jones's mother yeah in a
tweet
and his defense of that was just so
[ __ ] awesome
yeah it was just fantastic what do you
say he was just like hey man he
mentioned my dad i mentioned him i don't
care who's alive you bring a family into
it [ __ ] it those boys are ruthless man
those
those those younger fighters with social
media they're ruthless trolls on each
other
it's just like damned i heard you say
you know they were saying you know
comparing a fighter to like how many
people he can take out in a bar and you
said jon jones can take out
about 10 people at a bar at least what
can style bender take out
if jones jones is he tam stabbing has to
be right there
nine not eight or nine depends what city
where are we in albuquerque
are we in weehoe
and uh then the differential there
between the eight and nine
is just because stalin and israel are
sonya stellabender is fighting at
middle yeah he's a little smaller so if
there's a really big guy
maybe instead of one punch he takes two
punches how many people can you take out
of the bar you think comfortable
i don't know dude i don't know no idea
cause we're so far removed from that
i don't know right i don't know yeah
sure it'd be tough to find me in a bar
to start and then the other would be
i've never been in a street fight since
you know well how do you know you're
good at ufc fighting if you've never
been
like i figured you could call it right
that's like saying
you know it's just a sport so king henry
has ever been in a street fight
i mean growing up i i always thought you
would be like your whooping dude's asses
in high school you're like okay
i'm gonna play i'm upset no
to get into then not really most of most
that's what i think that's the
confusions most people think those guys
are like
bullies or barbaric or something no most
of them are martial arts
most i would guarantee most of them
haven't been in street fights yeah
those are pretty controlled and when was
the first time you got like really
punched in the face my brother i have an
older brother you speak the [ __ ] out of
me
yeah yeah you've been punched in the
face so it wasn't like oh [ __ ] no older
brother
yeah yeah so your story is that you're
fighting
and uh got into podcasting and then
stand up but just at the same time you
did both
uh so you weren't doing stand up yet
when we first met you were doing fighter
in the kid
i was doing fine kid we i was doing a
version because we're doing firing kids
live
right so that's how i kind of got
introduced to stand-up but
i was doing uh i was in the ufc but
when i was in the ufc halfway through my
career i moved to l.a
and uh brian kell was the first friend i
ever made
and so he wanted to start a podcast so i
was like i think i fought
four times before i retired but when i
came to la
that's when me and brian decided to
start doing a podcast so i was doing the
podcast while fighting
and it that was before everyone their
mom had a podcast so i was talking about
camp and my opponent and leading up to
the fight and people seemed to like it
and then it just kind of freaking took
off man and i remember
uh my last fight when i lost to travis
brown
i got a check for fighting him for
getting punched in the face and then
when i came home
from the event i got a check from doing
for advertising on the podcast
and the check for the podcast was more i
was like i'm [ __ ] out of here
that's great yeah so we're in a similar
situation where because
we were doing some other [ __ ] and then
we crossed over into stand up
yeah people people like to hate on us
and say oh they're not [ __ ] funny
they shouldn't be doing stand up they're
they got an unfair advantage because
they
you know already have an audience or
their buddies with joe rogan
yeah that that doesn't really work
though so as soon as you say oh the only
reason he has this you're out
like you're out you're you're part of
the problem i i think a lot of
and i stopped you know i don't see
anything on social media anymore i
haven't been on social media in
months i don't see any of it i a lot of
it is just
jealousy right because you know you're
kicking ass you're selling tickets on
the road
and i would say this anyone who's like
oh stevo's not funny or brennan's not
funny
you can find out if a person's not funny
because how long have you been doing
stand-up
ten years ten years and you've gone back
to markets how many times
five times so just so you morons know
the way comedy works is when you go into
city if you eat dicks if you eat all the
dicks
when you go back they do not buy tickets
yeah it's not even if they're like i
like steve i like them on jacket
it doesn't matter they're not buying
your ticket right so for you to come
back to a market
if you're selling more and more tickets
it means you're doing something right it
means you're funny
yeah so for me i always gauge my level
of stand up and how i'm doing depend
when i go back to markets if i'm selling
more and more tickets
sure and you know i want to be careful
not to blow too much smoke up your ass
but i [ __ ] really enjoy you
on podcasts like and i particularly like
you talking about fighting yeah you know
there's something about
listening to you know
you talk about fighting that's just
somehow like more compelling
you know and i just i like your your
angle on it you know thanks brother yeah
i appreciate it i uh
it's weird i only got really comfortable
talking about it probably
man i don't know i fell in and out of
love with it because
when i first got in the comments like
i'm a comic you know i'm not that fight
guy i'm a comic so
i was kind of i shied away from talking
about fighting getting so balls deep
into fighting
and then as of reece i'm like i love
fighting like i i love talking about it
like get into it man sure
because you can still do that you can
still be funny on these other podcasts
so
um just i just recently i started
getting comfortable and took that chip
off my shoulder
well i i like listening to you too
because when when you had that beef with
dana
yeah you would still do the news about
dana and it was completely unbiased
i was like oh [ __ ] like yeah i think
where uh
it makes me a little different than most
the other guys here in the mma space
is all of them need dana white all
either they work for espn
they work for dana in some regards or he
influences their show
i have nothing to do with i have nothing
to do
it doesn't matter i mean if he wanted to
he could he or if he he could try to
shut my showdown he can't
so those other guys they they have to
tread a line which sucks
you know and i don't and but and i give
dana a lot of credit too because when i
first started podcasting
because of the way he handled me when i
was in the fc the chip on my shoulder
was this [ __ ] big so i had venom in
my
veins man but it gave me the motivation
the fire
to start the podcast and just speak my
truth
and then now i look back i'm like what
are you so mad at man and i
have no ill will towards him if he
called me he was like hey brennan
can we come on your podcast to promote
ufc whatever 2-6 you're like yeah dude
whatever you want
dude dana white is the [ __ ] man it
depends
right it depends who you are it depends
who you are
because i guess because i'm in the
position i'm in now where
you know i'm like candy to frame
shawshank redemption i crawled through
the [ __ ]
i made it through the other side but
there's a lot of guys who are still in
that [ __ ] prison
and they're like yeah dude you're fine
but we're still broke over here man so
but the perspective i have now is i
don't know if i would run the ufc any
different than dana does
sure i think it's human nature to get
away with what you can in business
and like where uh
where there's um other situations
that um like they did
dane's got the whole [ __ ] monopoly on
the whole sport
you know like uh that's a good and a bad
thing if somebody's gonna leave say
you know all these people jon jones
jorge mosby all they're talking about oh
let me out of my contract i'm gonna take
off i'm gonna where are you gonna go
you're not gonna go anywhere that you're
gonna do better than the ufc
so dana white doesn't pay people simply
because he doesn't have to
agree yeah and that's the business plan
they they created but then also
you know before when their business
model was pay-per-views
they needed stars they needed the
ronnie's the brock lesnar's they needed
them because they made their nut
because they they they weren't owned by
wme now they're with wme
and they have this espn deal it doesn't
matter if the headlines two flyweights
if it's an all chick card they don't
give a [ __ ] about your ratings because
they're getting their nut from espn
sure so that's why when mazvadol or jon
jones or
any fighter goes pay me this or i'm not
fighting us cool dude don't fight
because all we got to do contractually
is line up these fights if we hit that
mark and he's like 40 fights
we hit that mark with 700 million no
matter who's on the card
right why because they get paid off of
like a guarantee like 700 000
pay-per-views
no they they don't even care about
pay-per-views as long as they deliver a
certain amount of fights to the espn
network
they get their money they they make no
matter what again so if it's jon jones
every other weekend
cool if it's billy who we've never heard
of
from the dana white contender series
cool as long as they
produce a fight they're good all right
but the cards have been [ __ ] awesome
though they've been amazing they've been
fun again and i know
i'm not hating on you see that's their
business model right i don't give a
flying [ __ ]
right i don't care what i care about is
that they're putting on fights
it gives me something to talk about and
i i don't give a [ __ ] who's fighting i'm
never going to miss a fight
dude i'm a degenerate i watch victor
i watch contender series oh yeah i
watched
mantis outside this rv dude i got
problems man
i don't even [ __ ] who's that bellators i
watch all watch it all huh
would you ever want to be an official
commentator man i gotta say brendan's
answer to this question
surprised me but what surprised me much
more
was how i managed to just play it off
throughout the whole episode as if i
wasn't totally
injured after the way i bruised my ribs
skateboarding at tony hawk's warehouse
just a couple days ago
i was trying a frontside 50 50 to
frontside board slide
just about landed it perfect except i
went flying from the top of the ramp
straight to my ribs on the cement and
it's killing me but it was totally worth
it
you know why because that little
skateboard session
at tony hawk's warehouse got me
the most intense workout i believe i
have
ever recorded with my whoop membership
that's right look at it right there 14.1
skateboarding baby this this
system is so intense it knows everything
this band it tells me like
everything about what's going on with my
body precisely
how much i'm sleeping what kinds of
sleep like how much time i'm spending in
deep sleep rem sleep like how much time
i'm just laying down
like it knows my heart rate variability
it knows when i'm working out it knows
what kinds of workouts i'm doing
it's got more insight than any fitness
tracker out there and i'm telling you
if you haven't tried it yet then it's
time for you to go to
woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
com and use the promo code stevo and you
get 15
off at checkout i'm telling you if
you're not getting on the woop
program you're kind of blowing it
because you could be a lot
healthier you could sleep better rest
better recover
better look better so one more time for
off at checkout you're going to
whoop.com using the promo code stevo for
off at checkout now let's talk about
commentary
yeah i don't know i you know i i don't
know i i
see the heat that rogan gets now that
he's like mainstream mainstream
and i don't know if guys because i feel
like i'm kept from the same class
i don't know if we're made for that
world because if you get to a certain
level
say this then the mainstream media is
like wait what what do you talk about
he was talking about like on yesterday's
podcast talking about fat [ __ ]
for an hour no we can't have this guy on
what are we doing dude
you know so um as far as the content gig
goes
this is where dana and i are different
um
you know i think he still has ill will
towards me so
i don't think until he dies until he
gives up the ufc
i'll never get opportunity to work with
ufc never
but take dana out of the equation i'm
friends with
every single person or every in from the
marketing department
the business side the refs the fighters
the coaches
people that work in the i'm friends with
everybody the snitch the golden snitch
novitskiy
we're all good i'm cool with everybody
but i think dana just has such ill will
towards me for whatever reason
um i don't think i'd get an opportunity
working ufc and that's ideally where i'd
work if i were to do it
but outside that you know i'm with
showtime which just
um signed a deal with bellator so
there's conversation there to bring me
into something like that but you know i
don't know
i don't know it's long story short i
don't know that's a long story
like so you're doing it
it was a long story i'm not saying so
you're okay dude
is show okay first of all is conor
pacquiao happening
or no that's not supposed to absolutely
[ __ ] on that was the prop
for all the embarrassing things that
have come out
you know regarding conor mcgregor i
would say that this
pacquiao business is probably the worst
well but here's the only thing with that
is it's hard to be like oh that's all
[ __ ] because there's a few
i'll say this if conor want that to
happen it would happen
they have the same manager they're both
down to take the fight
but i think conor it would ruin his
legacy if he went that route right now
because he's in his prime for him he
cares about his legacy in the ufc
so if he cares about that which he does
that's why you're going to see a dustin
poirier fight
or tony ferguson fight i couldn't
believe that mcgregor accepted the
poirier fight
really well i know that he's starched
poirier in the past
but long time ago since then poirier has
been
unbelievable monster wars like
stylistically though for conor if
if you were to if you're conor's manager
uh i think his name's audi
audio tear if you're his manager you
look at the roster
tony person's tough fight gaity
tough fight but not terrible for him
khabib awful fight
doesn't pour a pretty good fight guys
ranked number two i think got
lightweight like not a bad gig
why wouldn't you do massive at all then
that with connor cause maslow's too
heavy
he's 170. so it's like we need to get
connor on the path to get a title
we need him to get a title shot so you
got to do it at 55. he's not true seven
here but isn't he saying he feels better
at set 170 that's [ __ ]
but so for him it's like we got to quit
doing the spectacles
we can't fight moz at all we can't fight
pacquiao no not stop that
fight at 55 do work man
you think conor mcgregor can beat justin
gaichy
uh so i conor to beat khabib is
the absolute nightmare for him could he
do it maybe i'm a big connor fan can he
do it
maybe but hit stylistic against gaitre
because gaechi doesn't want to wrestle
get you want to sit on the outside
fancy himself a striker if it's a
striking match i'll take conor in that
fight
okay really and conor's not been known
to like
shy away from a fight anyway right even
if it's a tough fight
he was trying to fight diego sanchez
just stay active and those are the
league dm's
i think i think that the diego sanchez
was
a little bit embarrassing what is it
with dana it's like dude i can't
dude like i can't do that too dude diego
sanchez is 39 years old it's like
and 39 in the ufc he's been fighting
since what tough two
right and he's just not there there's
something [ __ ] like there's something
off
yeah it starts with this crazy coach
yeah but it's like you know he's 39 he's
he's 120 you know he's sold
yeah wow it's not that was a bad luck to
even
i don't know if it's a bad look because
everyone was matched up they weren't
giving anybody he's like dude give me
any
give me [ __ ] diego he just won and
danny's like i can't do that why
wouldn't he ask for nate diaz
that's the thing that's like no it's not
the fight you're casual that's not the
fight
yeah you're such a casual who looks like
scott might have lost some points with
brendan right there
nobody wants to be casual especially not
with the ladies
you want things to get serious and maybe
even
have somebody venture into your undies
right now that happens boys what are the
ladies gonna find are they gonna see
that you're a mess down there
oh dude you don't want that that's why
we have manscaped these are the most
important grooming products a man can
have for example
the lawnmower 3.0 that's the greatest
ball trimmer there is in the whole wide
world comes with a light so you can see
what you're trimming
if you can't go wrong with this thing
again it's the best
in the world comes with ball deodorant
with all the skateboarding i'm doing
trust me my balls
need this manscaped ball deodorant
they've got the best products for
grooming out there man
the weed whacker this takes care of all
my nose and ear here
that's right i said it i got nose and
ear here
but not anymore because i
we'd whack it away yeah man so i ask you
gentlemen how serious are you with the
ladies and are they taking you seriously
because you gotta have your stuff
groomed and i want manscape to help you
out too
so you're gonna go to manscaped.com
stevo what are you gonna get you're
gonna get 20
off your order and free shipping that's
20 off your order with free
shipping if you go to manscaped.com
stevo yeah dudes so get your balls in
order
and now let's watch how scott handles
this
because i'm not making fun of you but
that most people i get that all the time
i get that all the time like when i go
to starbucks like dude nate diaz connor
like you got you got to stop that
because it's a big money fight
that fight's never going anywhere so
connor could fight
gaichi fight pory win those lose the
belt to khabib
do his run he could get older the
trilogy fight that's never
ufc has that in their back pocket
whenever they want they're going to wait
for both of them to do their work and
they're like
all right let's do it that's what the
people want but that's not like that
fight does nothing for any
what do you what do we do with that
whoever wins that what do we do with it
you know
what do you do with that like it's not
going to progress anybody's career
like nate d you know nate diaz what
weight would they fight at
diaz is 170. price 70 i wish he'd come
down to 55 if they were to
uh do you know the trilogy fight but i'd
assume 70.
but again if con for conor be taken
serious by the masses
he has to fight a true contender not
these
one-offs of nate diaz or mazda doll or
pacquiao
he has to really dive in at 55 and it's
[ __ ] stacked dude
it's murderers row i feel like here's
the thing he can do it
he just has to commit i feel like he's
got too much going on
extracurricularly to like make a move
for the belt in 55
because it's whiskey the court cases
probably parting too much like having
too much fun being rich just having too
much fun
i need you to continue the conversation
while i get wendy water
okay does connor being in the position
he's in have any leverage with dana to
get more money or even him he has all
the leverage literally all the leverage
he's the
and that's why i think he's like the one
guy that's why i ride so hard
because everybody in the ufc i look at
like the circus all the fighters are
normal gray elephants conor's the one
green [ __ ] elephant
everybody's gonna pay to see so he
finally can ask for more peanuts so
i think i just like that he has the ufc
brass by the balls
look at the way he talks to dana yeah
look at that he leaks his dm's he's like
you can do [ __ ]
yeah and then how about he goes all
right dustin poury
let's do a exposition fight we'll just
do an amster fight on our own
on our own and then he's like no no
please please please no we'll do it here
it's like that's what i thought dude
i just love it's not that i dislike dana
i
like when somebody sticks it to the man
sure and every time conor fights
he sticks it to the man you're talking
about a kid what five years ago was on
welfare
now he's the most powerful most famous
fighter on the planet
in any combat sport yeah what is that i
mean how do you go from
being on welfare to being that guy
talent
i think it's the perfect storm is chris
being from dublin
his mind is his style was it five years
only
it's about about five or six years his
first fight 2014.
well he's taking some time off so let's
say six years ago six years ago you're
talking about kid on welfare and i think
it's like that that dream it's like a
hollywood movie it's yeah yeah it's
crazy
and yeah he has all these shenanigans
outside
of the ufc which you know giving give
any kid a hundred million dollars and
see how you're gonna respond
you know of course you're gonna have
something to be nuts well even dana when
he was on our show
he talked about how the reason conor's
got to be so big is that he won
and then he kept taking fights and kept
risking it like risking that leg and
winning and calling it out and winning
yeah but
it's like any of these guys you had uh
jon jones on here right yeah
so people want to give him [ __ ] dude try
being the youngest champion
ever to do it having that skill all that
money and not [ __ ] things up
was he 20 he was 21 youngest champion
when he
when he beat uh shogun i found the same
card try being that guy dude like you
even have some mistakes
i can't believe anyone who's young and
famous and not like
addicted to cocaine and drunk driving
and just doing everything crazy like how
do you not
it's weird to me people can't comprehend
it like with bieber they're like exactly
he needs to see a therapist i'm like if
you [ __ ] think yeah
the kid's been in a fish he's been in
the truman show since he was
eight years old he's on youtube playing
the goddamn drone drums on the side of
the street
yeah his dad's a piece of [ __ ] you know
he's like trying to figure it out man
sure and you want to pretend like that
wouldn't be you if you were
a 150 millionaire like 18. steve and i
were talking about that yesterday like
the
the age you blow up is like the age you
stop emotionally developing
right because it's all this [ __ ] happens
yeah cause we're talking about macaulay
caulking so it's
it's almost like the younger you are
when you
when you blow up like you're more [ __ ]
because it's like i think that's a good
point temper tantrums and like
but also nothing like you don't learn
you don't get any light real life
lessons like
you have entourage around you everyone's
doing everything you need anything you
need they get it for you
yeah it's like you have this weird
talent everybody everybody needs
something from you so you're talking to
people different like nobody treats you
like a human so
yeah it has to be [ __ ] weird crazy
dude that'd be weird
um so so uh have you done any shows
um comedy shows in the the pandemic in
the
yeah i did yes of course you have the
most prolific
[ __ ] how did i ask that yeah yeah i
was one of the
i was one of the canaries in the coal
mine i came back with a cough
do you have the antibodies right now oh
yeah i'm straight you've been tested
i've been test i actually have someone
come in uh today to test me again
because i'm doing a rob deredick show on
thursday
and they make you take a bunch of tests
either ridiculous yes cool have you done
it before
yeah i'm actually the i'm do i'm
shooting three on thursday i'll be the
most reoccurring guest ever
congratulations oh yeah that's our
people yeah i love rob man
yeah i [ __ ] love rob yeah so
uh i did chose and i didn't i guess i'd
you know
i didn't really think there'd be much of
a blowback but people were pissed
yeah dude you were so mad we were
talking about that on the fighter and
the kid
uh what's the comment
the only thing that killed at brendan
and brian's show was
uh the the fans got covered that coveted
the only thing
killing at a brendan i saw that
yeah so i got that and then i was down
for i was still podcasting and i was
down for like
i had no i was like i was fine a day
later people like i got like death
threats like i hope you die that's what
you get
so weird like all my my entire family
got it my
mother-in-law father everybody got it i
get it from you yeah oh geez yeah
were they like what the [ __ ] brendan
thanks a lot no i told them like i'm
gonna go stay at hotel like no just stay
in the basement quarantine stuff down
there so
i didn't see any i didn't see anybody
for you know didn't even hang out kevin
copeland
yeah they get it that's like the guy
who's like crushing up against
one pump gives her a [ __ ] herpes yeah
her kids are pregnant
no it was like yeah everyone got it but
everyone was fine but you said so
i was listening to the to your podcast
when you when you had it and
you were doing iv therapy and you were
doing like you did the hydrochloroquine
yeah the hydrochloroquine thing's weird
right because
rogan said that he's like oh you know
brendan did hydrochloroquine everyone's
like that's why you beat it you took the
trump drug
first of all um i didn't really like i
had like a mild symptom i see i don't
feel great
my doctor was like uh i can send you
some hydrochloroquine you take it
so i took it made me feel worse but not
like sick just
physically i felt like [ __ ] taking
malaria pills or something yeah they
made me i was like oh
and he goes then don't take it so i took
two hydrochloroquine pills
one one day and then waited another day
took it and i was like i don't feel good
stop taking it but i didn't need
anything to do i didn't it's just yeah
are you less afraid of it now that
you're like you've had it i've never
been feeling like
a lot i've never been afraid of it ever
that's why i was like
if i get it cool man you know i look
again i look at the stats and i go all
right so
99 people i get are fine unless you're
obese or you got underlying health
conditions
we're just going to stop what am i
supposed to do man yeah so i took the
risk and
i got it brian got it my whole family
got it everybody's fine
you know i've been back on the road
several times since then and business as
usual
and you sent me a photo from addison
texas
they're not like limited capacity
they're just 100
full room yeah they didn't give a [ __ ]
like they i think i think they said it
was 85
capacity and every show i mean there's
people to the back wall that's the
picture i said you know
i go dude this is 85. he goes we just
say that for you
l.a [ __ ]
addison texas is the place to cross the
street from hooters addison texas
right yeah yeah dallas yeah yeah that's
dallas
yeah there's right across the street
there you go that's where that uh
that what the manager name is
uh
yeah that's funny dude yeah that that
guy's hilarious
where else have you been touring uh
let's see
dude phoenix phoenix doesn't give a [ __ ]
dude i was in
phoenix was the first date i did and i
was like oh everybody here getting
coveted they were yeah i mean you
thought it was spring break
girls of the shirts off it's packed
clutch
live and i'm actually back there
november 5th through the 7th that's a
huge club what's the capacity of 5 50.
five something and it's
that they were not messing around man
are there they didn't putting 550 in
there
and you're going back in february i'm
going back in november
november 5th and 7th because first time
i went it was a brian cowan brendan show
and then they were like hey can we come
back at him i'll come back out there
dude completely different material
uh majority of it probably probably
eighty percent all new material yeah
cause i only did about
15-20 minutes with brian yeah be all new
material yeah
[ __ ] does it feel good to be back on the
road hell yeah man and i got i get this
and actually
uh it started after i watched after we
talked i watched your special that night
oh no wait thank you [ __ ] crush
i just my take away from your specials
it's so
and that's why i said in my uh post like
it's so entertaining
it's so good and just the just the the
video stuff you do i said i got to step
up my video game man and even the
highlight you sent me like i just got to
step my game
up so i hired a guy so i got a guy
coming with me on the road now to shoot
footage and like just some raw footage
and then i'll probably put out
15-20 minutes of new material in
december january online somewhere
nice man but you you inspired me man i
was like i gotta step my game up man
yeah i appreciate that man and that dude
i [ __ ] saddle like i told you i sat
on that thing for two and a half years
man
i taped it back in january of 2018
and that's the one piss for about it for
now is that doing stand up since then
there's
still been way more improvement you know
so yeah that's not representative of uh
yeah isn't it weird yeah and i think
that's why to your point that's why
like i have this like 15 20 minutes of
material on corona and my
and you know my buddies getting accused
of getting cancelled
so i have this this material i'm like
well how long am i going to be able to
use that before we get into 2021
and i've gotten so much i've improved so
much at stand up with my delivery and
writing jokes stuff like that since my
special
it's like i'm gonna put something out
man that's great man yeah
but you inspired it you inspired it i'll
be honest thank you
i feel like they got to be hurting for
new material for because everybody
nobody's doing stand up so they're
probably not getting any new
stand-up material for any of these
networks right because nobody's
practicing and
yeah i heard netflix had like stockpiled
so so many i know i know netflix
last year because uh two uh theo and i
think uh
schultz were talking with them i'm
pretty sure they greenlit 600 specials
yes 600 600 and that was like a year and
a half ago so they were
they have some in the tank right it's
crazy um
no now you just said that you're doing
material about your buddies getting
canceled
we were we were honestly like paul
brought he says he says
about that i probably shouldn't ask him
about that i was like i don't want to
ask him but maybe you can
open your fire away man i'm going to
open i mean i'm just curious like
your perception of how that went down i
mean it's uh
i don't you know i i don't think
anyone's ever like equipped to deal with
that you know because
you know brian's been so influential on
me and he's been such a positive
person in my life and he's just you know
from what i know brian county is a great
dude
he's been so supportive of me yeah yeah
he's always thought very highly of you
and
so for me it's just it's just such a
weird world because
where i come from when i was having my
issues with dana white or i was having
my issues with
fox or anything i get on this is my
weapon i get on the mic and i [ __ ] i go
man
i don't pull any punches and i even if
i'm in the wrong i i'd say it on the mic
so my initial reaction was to get on
there and [ __ ] go
and uh brian's like you can't do that
buddy i'm like what do you mean i can't
do he's like you can't do that it's
gonna end up it's gonna hurt me more
it's gonna help me
i want you to do nothing i'm like
alright well i'll let you do it he goes
i can't be there and i'm like what do
you mean you can't beat he's like i
can't be
associated with it anymore not right now
i can't until we figure more things out
until the process
um goes along further there's nothing i
can do
so i guess for me
you know if i'm being dead honest it's
it's more of like
in l.a i feel so lonely because my guys
left man
my guys left so rogan's gone right who's
you know he's a mentor
and one of my best friends and he leaves
and i still talk to him every day but
it's just different when he's not here
so he leaves theo moves to nashville
even though i
still see him every other week because
we do kings thing but he's in nashville
he's doing that remotely no he flies in
we shoot like two episodes and he flies
back out wow
yeah that's crazy yeah he's the man so
he flies here but
you know i realized theo man would he'd
be at my house
every other day playing with my kids and
stuff like that so theo's in nashville
um you know and then brian i can't you
know i can't
be on ear with brian and then it's just
like you know the rat pack broke up so
yeah it's just it's lonely man so what
are you doing it's heartbreaking
trying to i'm tr you know again i don't
think there's any book i can buy that
when your friend gets accused of rape
this is how you deal with during a
pandemic
yeah so it's like um
fighting the kid has given me so much
it's like that's my baby what people
don't realize is
you know for a long time fire kid wasn't
important to brian brian was a big actor
and
brian had stand up and all i had i had
fighting and podcasting
and uh i loved the podcast and um i put
everything into it so there's days where
me and brian were getting fights because
i begged him to come and do the show
because it was never his thing
he like his friends made fun of him for
doing podcasts hollywood friends
and now who's laughing all these dumb
asses have one but
so for me like that's always been my
ride or diet fire in the kids so
um i'll be honest there there's probably
about a month to go i was just like i
should probably
shut this thing down i have my two other
shows i'm fine
and then i gave a lot of thought about
it and asked chappelle lacy and uh malik
b
to do the podcast with me these guys are
great yeah they're so much fun
josh wolf's good too josh but i i really
think there's something special with
chappelle
and malik and i just i have fun again
but um
you know we're probably gonna have to
rebrand it and stuff like that but it's
uh
you know it's [ __ ] it's hard it's
straight up heartbreaking man it's
heartbreaking
are you gonna move or you're gonna stay
in la i'm gonna wait after the election
and then i'm gonna give it some time
after that see if la bounces back
and uh if it's still north korea here
i'll probably move
wow you know what you said something
about brian callan not being uh
like super into the fighter and the kid
but i remember brian had his own podcast
before fighter and then he had 14
listeners and i went over to his house
and did his podcast like in his kitchen
or something i think
and uh and i was like wow yeah this uh
this isn't that big of an operation and
then
what year was that i don't know
13 2012. something like that yeah 2013
sounds about right and um
and so then the fighter and the kid and
it was crazy because
it's like wow i got the
feedback that i got after doing the
fighter the kid i heard about it from
everyone i think i said on the podcast
like hey if you're listening tweet me
and it was just like flooded with two
years ago yeah we have this ride-or-die
fan base man and i think
again i think what's tough is not not be
able to get on the mic mike hey
this is what's going on this is why
brian's not on the show but
i just contractor and legally i can't do
that and it [ __ ] kills me man
because they're probably like what the
where's where's brian i'm like dude
trust me
i wish she was here but just it's out of
it's out of my control are you talking
to him pretty regularly
every day every day and you were
supposed to i still
you know i don't think brian cares if i
devolve
divulge this information i still give
brian half the pay
even to this day even if he never does
the show again he'll still get
money but you were going to do patreon
for a minute
i remember you guys were getting on that
that was my idea for brian so
he couldn't come back on the regular
firing the kid so i go dude so
what would do is a a patreon and would
you call find the rings and i had a
my guy create a theme song we had the
logos everything
and brian's like you can't do that bubba
like what he's like we can't do that
either
so he goes let me do this you carry fire
in the kid do what you want with it
i'll do the patreon it's going well for
him the patreon is going well for him
you know so he has the patreon with sam
tripley has his own show on there too
and then he's doing the road so you just
got to hope
you know with everything going on that
yeah so when he's saying we can't do
that that's to protect
you yes that's why he's and so and
you're saying he
was the one who he decided to step away
from finding the kid you were like come
on let's come
on let's talk about it let's just take
it head on yep wow
yeah that's wow that's admirable of him
to protect you in this i would imagine
that's like
again that's what's tough for me right
because um
brian's i i just i can't picture him
being accused of what he did you know i
i don't i've never seen that sign i know
that guy man i know brian so
it's for me it's tough it's it's really
tough man because
brian's been such a positive person in
my life and
got me into stand-up and he's the one
who believed me when nobody did doing
stand up became my first show
uh at the comedy store in the belly room
while you know when nobody was laughing
brian was laughing and he goes just keep
doing it just keep doing it keep doing
it
so um again i don't care what
whatever happens to brian i have no i
and i don't know what's gonna happen to
brian
but whatever it doesn't matter brian
will always receive payment from me
that's my that's my obligation to brian
kellen
i owe him that yeah that [ __ ] rules
man super cool
yeah it was weird because when you when
you came in here
i was like oh i think we met before but
i know we've met before and i don't know
why i said that
but i always remembered you before steve
went to do the fighter in the kid
right i've had a good conversation i've
always told steve i was like i've always
liked you
i've always supported you because how
cool you were to me yeah and i was just
like dude that went a long way
he's not he's not kidding at all yeah
like because we we went to
i remember getting like [ __ ] dog food
or something we met at whole foods or
something
yeah you got dog food there though yeah
we got a big old bag of dog food
and uh yeah we were all just kind of
hanging out and
um and and scott said like hey man you
know like
that's crazy i'm just like showed up as
like your buddy and
you know like you went out of your way
to make me feel comfortable ah that's
so i don't i mean yeah i don't i
yeah that's crazy i mean you remember
that i i don't i don't know how else to
act
that's why i think it's weird if
someone's like uh not that anybody's
ever said
if somebody's like stevo's an [ __ ] or
brian's an [ __ ] or
friends and ass i'm like i don't know
what you guys are talking about like i
don't associate with these people
i don't think i don't think a lot of
people will say that about me i think
i don't think anybody knows yeah in
general
it's easier to be nice it's just easier
to be a nice guy i think
yeah but it's also in my nature like you
know some guys
you know right it's just i don't know
what else to do well it's because
probably you guys
blew up after you guys were kids like if
you guys were child stars like [ __ ] you
you know well there's not a lot of child
star podcasters either and also
but also i'm not that famous you know
what i'm saying like no you're
famous uh i mean in our small bubble
you know in like our in our world i
guess but your small bubble gets
billions of views
on the yeah there's different levels
like to me like famous is like
chappelle burr rogan like that's you
know and i don't know if i'm equipped
for that i might
if you do that you might come back in
two years from now when i'm really
famous i'm gonna have a coke problem
you know how [ __ ] great bill burr on
saturday at live
it's bill burbey and bill byrd man it's
so it's so funny to me it's so
refreshing because
we're in this world cup culture you need
you need real guys like bill burr
you we need bill burman he's a zebra out
there you know
yeah yeah he doesn't give a [ __ ] what
people say about him and he just i don't
know what people expected like you've
you've never seen bill burr before like
that's bill being bill like
he didn't tailor that to upset people he
didn't tailor that
for the saturday life crowd he did what
bill bird does his true fans are like
[ __ ] yeah that was dope
the people who don't know who is like oh
my god i'm so upset he's like that's why
i did it
that's why i did it you morons so he's
great yeah yeah he's good
dad [ __ ] fantastic yeah what an
accomplishment too for him to be on
i mean how many stand-up comics just get
awesome
that's rare that's a small group if
there's a bucket list you know that's
that'd be number one
saturday live man stand up would you
ever want to do that steve host snl
i don't think i have to worry about that
i don't know that uh that's in my future
i'd like to think really
but would you accept if they are of
course i like to think that that i'm
getting some traction and i'm doing what
but i'm in bra
i'm in brendan's boat you know i'm like
not that big of a deal i'm
not pretty famous steve i hustled pretty
hard you know i'm i'm reasonably
successful but i'm not that like
main guy that's gonna be on i mean but
when jack has four is coming out i mean
they had knoxville do it
i wouldn't i wouldn't be that surprised
well no if you if
yeah i mean that you're at least like
you know stevo's host i'm like oh [ __ ]
yeah
that makes sense right and i'd watch
because maybe he's gonna do some kind of
stunt in a skit or something i don't
know i'd be intrigued they could use it
too
what kind of guests do they have on
there who who's the host normally like
what kind of people
it's always different it's usually
actors you know yeah actors uh
people who are super a-list people not a
ton of comedians
but i also i feel bad for bill doing it
or bird doing it for
during covid because i'm sure it's not
the exact same
like they're doing the table read
everyone's [ __ ] mask on it's weird
like i'd be like if they offer it to me
like is there any way we could do it
next year yeah
so i can get the full experience
yeah and then they're like we thought
this was make a wish like we're trying
to help you out here dude
they just brought up uh punky johnson or
is it punky johnson
at the comedy store they she's a cast
member
like she was a regular at the store oh
really i think
if i'm saying that name right i'm not
sure i'd be curious how many people are
actually watching saturday night live
now
like when it actually airs you know they
some of their clips go viral especially
like burst stuff
the actual show like tv is kind of dead
our last guest on here was keenan
thompson
and and i asked him if he knew what the
split was between
actual television viewership compared to
youtube
viewership and he was he just said well
it's obviously
important the youtube piece because they
do they do hurry those clips online
they bust them out fast that burp uh
monologue was up
i mean that night i think sure sure and
and i think that uh
it i i would love to know i would love
to know
like the odd size of the audience tv
versus youtube
but the youtube numbers are pretty
[ __ ] impressive numbers are good but
you can
and i'm not i'm not you know hating on
any of the saturday life cast members
some of those guys are my heroes but
you've recently too you've seen some of
those cast members leave
and then they do the road and they're
not selling like crazy tickets
right so to me that's it's not that
they're bad
at stand-up comedy to me it means that
science life's not that their demo is
not that big
how does pete davidson do on the road
does he i think he
he doesn't do the road he used to
yeah but not like he he he does like he
did some spots around new york and then
i mean he's at the store because uh
chappelle asked him to open up for him
when
chappelle came back started doing shows
and pete was like i've done stand-up in
like a [ __ ] year dude so
he came to the store and was trying new
material oh he was eating [ __ ]
because it's all new material but he's
just trying to get through it yeah yeah
he doesn't
i like like for a special i love i love
pete dave he's great love him
but he it's he's not like a you know a
road dog
like when he's getting ready for his
spouse she's not a road dog but what he
was though right that's usually yeah
yeah i think he started stand up when
he's like 16. that's that's
hilarious yeah i love him he gets just
got his chicks biggest dick ever
big dick energy i'd love to see
how obvious was that chris evans like oh
my god did i do that
why did he does he have a big [ __ ] it's
all right but it's like
it's good it's good kind of like captain
captain america didn't he's like oh my
god i can't believe i did that it's like
come on [ __ ] what are you doing that's
so funny
that's like when lenny kravitz's pants
ripped open he just has the hugest [ __ ]
you're just like yeah he had a big one
and then tyga did the fans only yeah the
fans only
posted his dick on there he's working
with a piece with the dude bigger than
the captain america what
are there a lot of dudes on only fans i
don't think so but
also your career can be going great if
like if you guys like next month you're
like
you're brendan has the only fan's
account like i thought he was doing well
like it's not yeah like if you're
crushing life yeah you got to pay
you paid to see 100 i did obviously
people [ __ ]
screenshotted it and like if you post
your dick people can screenshot it yeah
so they screenshot and it just went
viral but
for him he's like yeah that's what i
wanted dude i want everybody to know i
get this giant ass dick
[ __ ] that's what i do is [ __ ] the
kardashian he used to
he's somewhere between like super rich
and totally in debt so that kind of
makes sense yeah
that's exactly what he is that's funny
yeah yeah only fans to me lets me know
you're not doing well
right the girls do very well on there
they crush it it's kind of like cameo
but then there's certain people who
they just they're insanely wealthy and
they're on cameo
do you do cameo i tried it for like the
shortest time i can't do it to me it's
such a bummer
i couldn't [ __ ] keep coming at me
like dude we get a lot of requests
having him like i ain't doing that
homeboy i tried it
and like like i had two problems with it
number one was that
every [ __ ] video i would like
just just put this pressure on myself to
make it
like super awesome you know i'd be like
hey man
you know i'm going to give you a sneak
peek at footage that's not been released
yet
get ready to check this out and then
like and i'd be trying
so hard that it was just like just too
much anxiety exhausting right it's just
i'm trying
how much were you charging uh [ __ ] i i
bounced around with it like a hundred
bucks i think
chris crystal got on there he did he
just got here to
piss off brian so brian was charging
like five dollars
seeing happy birthday everybody and
their [ __ ] mom for like seven weeks
straight
and we're like jesus christ dude chris
got on there
and his his minimum reserve was like
thirty five hundred dollars like yeah he
didn't get any
i don't think so he just did it he was
like i'll jump on there
and then set his reserve so high it was
like i think caitlyn jenner's the
highest though
right yeah but the other thing was
i remember you know like i would agonize
over like my my ratings
had to be like five-star ratings right
like then
then somebody gave me like a [ __ ]
shitty rating
and and after i gave i gave them a sneak
peek of unreleased [ __ ] footage
like went out of my way to try so hard
to make it like
super entertaining and and heartfelt
and this guy was like what like dude you
didn't read like the exact
[ __ ] words that i [ __ ] asked you
to [ __ ] read
and i was like cancel the whole [ __ ]
thing
i cancelled the whole [ __ ] thing i
was just like that's the thing about it
is that
you just feel like like i'm like
you're my [ __ ] birthday party clown
for the day you do it dead like do what
i want you to do
some people do it for charity which i'm
like oh that's cool man give them away
cherry
but then some people if someone's like
hey you know steve i was hustling on
camera like damn he's not selling
tickets on the road like
what's going on dude right i mean but
then there's but it's weird because
there's also like
you know like [ __ ] hugh jackman's on
there is he yeah like there's like big
tony
hawk is on there is he still on there
tony hawk i mean i don't know i don't
know but like i love tony hawk but if
you said tony hawk's other like
ah damn like he's not scaring
skateboards or right but dude he just
re-released his video game that has to
be kicking ass right
like dude it's insane video game money
and he said he had like like tony hawk
through five like [ __ ] underground
then re-released like he's video game
insanity
yeah it just doesn't make sense to me
like when dr drew on cameo he's on cameo
yeah and not only is he [ __ ] uh
podcast all over the place [ __ ]
headline news channel
[ __ ] like cnn so much going on cnn
money
[ __ ] his own medical practice he's a
yeah he's a current working doctor
non-stop
medical practice and then he came on my
show
uh you know he came on king and the
sting we haven't seen me in theo
and mike catherwood so we did like a
love line throwback with me and theo and
those guys
and then me and uh dr drew bonded over
90 day fiance
he's like who's your favorite and i was
like no it's my favorite so we had this
weird connection
after he's like you want to do a show i
was like what he's like you wanna do a
nine-day fiance show i'm like
no i don't like it that much dude but
we're considering and i go how do you
have the time dude how does he have the
time
to hauler oh he sent me a schedule i was
like well let's let's look at our
schedules trying to figure it out
our schedules didn't line up but he was
like i have these three days
in these three hours you got to come to
the house then i'm like yeah dude let's
just skip it for now and what in those
three days you just blast out like nine
shows yeah blast them out that's how he
does it yeah that's
[ __ ] that's crazy and and on cameo
too i always know
like if you're on it that's fine but
like i'll know how popular or like how
big of a celebrity you are by how much
you charge people
you know like if you're charging like
400 for a cameo it's like
you don't really need it you're just
doing it whatever brian was charging
five dollars
that's why i'm dancing and [ __ ] i think
five dollars caitlyn jenner was like
or something like that proposed that
even feels like kind of low
she's a billionaire yeah she's got so
much money to be like if you want 30
seconds of my time
no not caitlyn caitlin's not bad she
killed a guy
but um she uh i thought you're saying
kylie jenner
kylie's a billionaire yeah kylie's
she's not a billionaire she's killed the
guy yeah she killed a guy
with the car right yeah no one talks
about it just like everything's all good
[ __ ] literally killed a guy it was a guy
there was a guy and she was the hummer
and ran to the back of it pch yeah right
up there
geez and we're just like oh that's cool
anyway you know
woman yeah you know
oh [ __ ] that's funny i saw her at
starbucks one time
and she had these two little dudes
following her around just like just like
so enamored with her they weren't with
her oh they were just like they were
just like
and they just she went to go order and
they went at the starbucks table sat
down and just stared at her
and then they just and i was like [ __ ]
man that's got to be tired dude i'll
tell you
and uh brian i mean three years before
caitlyn started making the transition
when it was bruce when the bruce the
bruce
brian three years before any of this
news came out he's like
dude i'm telling you bruce is
transitioning you're at your [ __ ]
mind dude
he goes no i'm telling you i got a buddy
who works on his house
and looked in the window and saw like
i'm telling you transition i go you have
your [ __ ] mind dude
and then probably like two years after i
i was at starbucks off pch
and uh at the time is a he was bruce and
but he had like this long ponytail yeah
and like these real
nice nails i'm like man maybe brian's
[ __ ] right pan [ __ ] until now i
mean yeah brian was dead on
damn where the pc in malibu yeah yeah
that malibu market uh-huh yeah cross
creek hell yeah
yeah that's funny are you talking about
vintage no no no
no the uh right by like uh malibu market
right there yeah
that's the spot man yeah if you want to
see jerry seinfeld go there
they have a porsche club that goes there
all the time i almost brought my car up
there but they're there every i think
like saturday
malibu's crazy because i used to live
there and uh at that at that starbucks i
i opened the door for some girl in the
like 6 a.m it was katie holmes
yeah [ __ ] like that you know it's like
oh wow if you're a star [ __ ] that's
the place to like chill out
grab a coffee you know yeah holding the
door open for like pamela anderson
you're like what
it's [ __ ] crazy yeah are we promoting
anything for you
thick boy when's this come out this
thursday oh damn this year like now dude
uh
yeah big boy gear big boy bike club is
thickboy.com
i'm in cycling are you inside like a
road bike
uh road bike but now i've got they're
making me a gravel bike oh sick
uh who's making it for me mosaics you're
gonna love that because i just got a
road bike
okay cool i get i actually i get it
saturday yeah from special did you
receive the text i sent one time and it
was like a screenshot of my strava and i
was like yo does this [ __ ]
oh no i didn't get it yeah i think it
was when you changed your number
i mean i was like i had like 600 feet of
climb
like beastie like uh rode for
roughly an hour maintained 15 miles per
hour
strolling man yeah i uh that's me
killing myself yeah that's going nuts
yeah yeah i'm uh i decided to get a road
or uh yeah road bike
uh because i work with specialized and
then uh i was like i wanna do
something cool man so i'm gonna ride
from san francisco to la
and then just give all the money to
charity so i'm gonna do that
december like 500 470 miles yeah it's
probably taking me five days
i'll sleep at night and then wake up
early are you gonna like have like
your [ __ ] sleeping kit on the bike
are you gonna be like no i'm not that
hardcore straight into a hotel yeah
four-star
yeah like four seasons yeah yeah yeah
hardcore i'm halfway tempted to try that
but i i don't
know if i could keep up i love it man i
did santa barbara to san diego
three days how was that it's cool
everybody it was camped out you're the
biggest [ __ ] ever on a bike no i just
hate bicycles you know it's like
well i like bicycling but it's still
like hell's gonna ride
and all of a sudden we're going to like
every bicycle shop in l.a
and i'm like why are we just like no i
want to go see to see if they have a
lock over here so we're going over there
he's like oh the one in la how's one
downtown okay cool then we're all
over there and then we got and then he's
like well dude i got a spot at the store
in 20 minutes we got to get an uber put
our bikes on the uber and then go to
it's like like do what the [ __ ] it's
just not if you want to do four to
six miles i would love to
but he'll be like too much you don't
want to go shopping on a bike dude 24
miles in you're like bro
[ __ ] dude
like you're just mad like not supposed
to be relaxing
yeah i uh i just dig right by myself
because i'm constantly talking to a mic
and i'm you know i got two kids so
there's all the
what's up this mic he's in the podcast
i was like what what mike yeah i was
like what mike because when i'm trying
to talk to people
on the while i'm biking i get all this
wigs
i
no thank god i can't so i just like get
on the bike put my headphones on and
cruising man i love it
i'm addicted to it uh i'm really into
ryan bingham right now
did you guys watch yellowstone oh yeah
of course that's my [ __ ] show well
ryan bingham's the witch guy
he's the the guy in the white hat who uh
they got out of prison
and then they kick him out right oh yeah
yeah the skinny he's a real singer
is he really yeah he's a real real
singer legit the singer best show on
television
agree 100 i'm actually headed to montana
next week
because i fell so much in love with that
show i was like i want check out montana
i'm so attracted to the the oldest the
daughter
oh beth yeah yeah she's pretty hot she's
my type yeah dude i
i told the the my agent uh represents
them i went dude if they put me in as a
thick ass cowboy or something as an
extra
i'll brand myself in montana i can see
that [ __ ] brand myself right now dude
yeah kevin costner it's like
he's probably my favorite like i like
rip
rip yeah rip man but i mean like just
making movies like if it's a kevin
costner movie you know it's going to be
good
is he though i was thinking about i
wasn't the biggest fan before this
because he did like dancing with the
walls right
yeah water world water world
feel the dreams that's a good one for
the love of the game
you're talking about the 90s bro you
know what i'm saying so it's like like
if he came out with a water world two
i'm not rushed into the movie thing what
did he just he just did uh
uh emily's game who what was that called
i don't know molly's game he was the dad
oh yeah molly's game yellowstone's so
goddamn good so good
what's up with thick boy that's your own
thing yeah
yeah think boy.com it's uh it's my it's
my it's the club it's the thick boy bike
club just thick dudes on bikes
and we started merch and then the boy
bike club and then we
we jumped on with we're doing a collab
with specialized so
cool yeah that's cool where are you
selling your merch at dickboy.com
right okay and how are the orders being
fulfilled
i have a whole filling station right up
the street you do it yourself
no of a company a company that does it
because
we're getting in the game dude you
definitely we're we're becoming our own
fulfillment center oh really you're
gonna do your own we were not no more
[ __ ] three pl dude we just got a
warehouse oh yeah
we're going if we're going in there
we're gonna have a warehouse manager and
uh doing it all in house
that's dope strategy ultimately we'll be
able to
to take people who don't have their
merch game
like going out and be like hey man like
we're gonna
we can bring you on as a client and do
better by you than
any of these 100 because they take a
chunk dude yeah
they take a huge chunk they take a chunk
now it's all in house
we're just gonna take a slice
how much how many products do you have i
thought you have mugs right is that
thick boy mugs
uh i don't we don't have think boy mugs
we got uh
hoodies tees hats shorts sweats
we got tie-dye stuff coming out the end
of this month and it's at thickboy.com
do you have a website
brendan's shop just think boy.com and
it's all right three c's thick
three c's that's stick with i only
copyright on three c's
two c's i can't tell you three c's is
what i did three series that's you
super thick i'm three c's and uh i'm
surprised you're not getting into the
shoe game yet or is that
i would love to i'm such a freaking
sneaker head but it's like
nike doesn't give a [ __ ] like what yeah
dude we work with jordan dumbass you
know so
right i'm a sneaker head by trait like a
[ __ ] so
we're getting in the shoe game
i'm like i thought we were really
starting to kill it and then we rolled
up your driveway and i'm like
[ __ ] we got work to do
yeah i'm exhausted though man i'm
exhausted though
are you nah i shouldn't say that no my
gig is actually pretty easy
for a week girl yeah really like when do
you work
i really like this tv show i saw heading
up to montana just to check it out
when you actually work dude no it's a
lot
i would do it for free you know they
just happen to compensate me for it
yeah stand up too i absolutely [ __ ]
love it man so i mean
the the comedy club grind gets a little
bit groundhog's day
it gets tough man like my uh i didn't i
don't know if it's ct or i just
do so many shows like my brother's like
oh we've been here for remember this is
this like
i don't dude like we could do stand up
in iraq
looks the exact i don't get to see much
yeah it's like
show hotel show hotel show and then i
might play it like yeah like it's all
the same [ __ ] do you work out on the
road
because i don't sit in a bath all day on
the road it depends like when i was in
utah they have great
mountain biking there so we drove up
there uh
and did mountain biking there it depends
what city yeah every city we go to
there's a bunch of bros you're like dude
come the gym let's roll
like no dude i'm all set on dudes dude
i gotta give you this man we got this in
amazon finally
oh damn that's dope stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole oh wow
is it really hot it's so [ __ ]
delicious man like we didn't put too
much emphasis on making it
hot we put the emphasis on delicious and
tasty
it's so delicious dude your butthole
probably will find out yeah because
you'll eat enough
oh hell yeah i like you know my girl's
straight mexican mexican
she loves spicy [ __ ] and i can handle
spice like she'll make homemade salsa
like she mate this morning for a
breakfast
she's always making homemade salsa she's
gonna love this but on
this week's king of the sting i don't
know whose [ __ ] idea it was but
it was like a tick tock like viral thing
where there's those hot
chips tortilla chips that are mixed with
like ghost peppers and something else
yeah i just seen that yeah so they're
like oh they're like we should all eat
one on air and i'm like i can handle hot
stuff not a big deal
dude it [ __ ] me up king in the rings
thing
i think uh i think that the hot ones
people are doing that the chicken is
cheap
it's so hot but it's not like fun hot
it's not it's like you're supposed to
buy it and like make a youtube video of
yourself eating it like like
feels like i like he just saw white and
his eyes were like
dripping wet and like i couldn't i
couldn't feel my mouth
it wasn't fun this is this you're just
gonna
enjoy it and i wanted to enjoy it it's
hot it's hot but it's something
when you guys are all you guys shoes
merch
it's fun doing these business adventures
right like i launched uh
my own whiskey line in january damn it's
that
two-year process is it is it working
well we launch it in january we have
we have distribution it's a japanese
whiskey it's gonna be sick man japanese
whiskey
what's it made out of what do you mean
what like it's it's
so what is whiskey made out of it's uh
rye rye yeah so it's gonna be like a
uh a blend but it's japanese whiskey and
actually the
the manufacturer and the the plant is
actually in uh
japan that's cool and then they bottle
in atlanta it's like
lost in translation where he's drink
he's the japanese whiskey
uh commercial dude yeah no but i'm
excited
yeah cool story on that note see you
guys later
like no nobody thank you dude that
that's
[ __ ] awesome man what a blast let's
cut you loose dude this is
all right man this dog's [ __ ] dope
yeah she is do you have a dog
you know i found her in the streets of
peru oh really brought her home she's a
street dog from south america
damn super chill that's why she was just
eating your trash
running around i was like oh yeah
hopefully he doesn't have a yeah we were
in here with ryan scheckler the skater
yeah i love that
dude she [ __ ] farted so bad that was
the worst fart i think i've ever been
trapped in
boy this dog hit the [ __ ] lottery on
the street
ass finds her she has like 300 000
instagram followers hell yeah
yeah she's a good girl dog man well hey
dude thank you so much man
yeah thank you man i'll be in phoenix
november 5th through the 7th
and then the week after that i'm in
nashville at zany's cool man yeah so
nashville man you're making me want to
get back on the road dude
you should do it man you really are and
if you're in the same city man come
i'd love to have you that'd be so fun
yeah fans would go nuts
dude i'm [ __ ] tempted man like uh
wait what days you got
uh phoenix stand up live is november 5th
through the 7th
and then nashville i think is the week
after that like the 11th through the
30th yeah
i could see driving to phoenix man i
don't know it's an easy drive i don't
need any excuse to do that let me know
dude i'll [ __ ] come do a set for you
that'd be dope man i would love that
capacity yeah tfk.com for tickets
thirsty dude i'm talking right on man
thank you
thank you brother man i have always just
really liked brendan's shop
man and uh i also really like you guys
the street team the people who stick
around at the very end of the podcast
and i like to tell you special stuff at
the end of the podcast
and this week i'm going to tell you that
for
brendan's shows at stand up live in
phoenix
it's uh november 5th 6th and 7th
thursday friday saturday
it's possible not even very likely that
we're going to load up the rv the
podcast studio van and drive on out to
phoenix
maybe i'll be a special guest at one or
two i don't know maybe none but
possible that if you go see brendan's
shows in phoenix that uh
that i'll be there um he got me really
excited about
doing stand-up again so yeah dudes uh i
gotta go
like ice my ribs or something love you
dudes